there are some Industries in which you
have teams of 50 or even 100 specialist
just reviewing
vendors just analyzing this information
it's still not enough but for them it's
really important because they really
care about
[Music]
risk UD coin welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
today I'm really excited to talk to you
all things security GRC compliance gen
um H where the end of
2023 and so obviously a lot to unpack in
in this whole Space your own background
is fascinating and I and I'd love to
start there so again thank you for being
here take me a little bit through your
journey um um leading up to this world
of security questionnaires what What's
Happening Here
yeah so what's um I'm a technology I'm
my core is
technology and like five to seven years
ago kind of late I I started to really
be focused on
AI um and about um especially about
linguistic AI I thought that there is a
very strong potential over there
um that that was like a few years before
CH GPT and but but it was clear that it
was going there uh because a lot most of
the information today is at least the
processible information is the text so a
lot of information and um the technology
was moving really fast over
there uh so and also we were looking for
some places that where you have a lot of
um where language is the base the base
of the work like and if you're familiar
with the GLC area security compliance
and risk management this is all about
text you need to read a lot you need to
write a lot H generate policies respond
to questionnaire analyze hundreds of
vendors reads their hundreds of pages of
documents and evidence their responses a
lot a lot of language and not an easy
language to read or to write it's a
combination of security technology but
also legal
compliance not not easy and just for the
context because it's important it's you
know what is what is GRC how did this
emerge you know why do we have these GRC
questionnaires now as part of our as
part of our processes
ER yeah so um GRC stands for governance
risk management and
compliance H you for
example most of security incidents may
may it be
[Music]
um
ransomware or data Bridge it have to do
with the vendors 67% of the security
incidents start with your technology
vendors and it makes because your
information gets to hundreds of vendor
and you're also dependent on hundreds of
vendor to be able to provide the service
or the product you provide you cannot do
it without other ER other companies
contributing whether it's contributing
tools or contributing software
contributing a so there it is much more
likely that one of them will be the
source of the problem than what you do
internally but how do you verify your
vendor how do you make sure that they
are complied with privacy how do you
make sure that they are they secure
themself that the information that you
share with them will not be lost that
they will not have a ransomware attack
that will stop their business continuity
and it will affect your business
continuity every security ER expert
knows that it's very difficult to keep
even your own organization secured when
you have full visibility
but when you need to make sure that your
vendor or third party is secured it is
much more
difficult you have hundreds of vendor
and you have very little
visibility you and even if you had full
visibility you cannot you cannot just
can't too much information for a human
being to process and
analyze and how does the GRC help
mitigate that risk of having so I
understand the risk you have hundreds of
different vendors coming in to assist
you because you know everybody's working
on piece of the puzzle and you were
piecing it together to a workflow and a
product for customers and then how does
this world of
GRC help mitigate the risk that one of
these vendors will be the source of
issue okay so um a part of DRC is a
third party risk management and as part
part of the ref fired party risk
management is that you need to verify
each one of your vendors this is the the
process the problem is that until now
until today it was not feasible too much
data too much too many
vendors ER so this is why we our thought
was okay now we have generative AI now
we can train a model to operate like a
GLC expert and finally this
bottleneck of understanding the vendors
analyzing the risk based on the enormous
information that they share with you
finally it's
feasible so this very important process
of vendors ver third party
verification that until now was just a
tick the
Box ER activity because everyone knew
that this is not real they knew that
they cannot really do it right because
not enough resources in the world to
deeply assess hundreds of
vendors and now it's for the first time
it's actually
feasible and this that will contribute
to the security to the overall security
overall privacy but not only that any
new regulation you will think about
whether it's AI related or ESG every
time that you want to make a real change
in the world
and to make sure that it's comply in the
entire to the entire industry this is
the first time with the generative AI
it's the first time that it's actually
doable that can you can actually verify
every company in the world and make sure
that they are all comply with this new
regulation until now it was not real it
was a tick the Box activity and everyone
knew that and now you can finally do it
so is there a different is there an an
evolving expectation from regulators and
cisos to transition from ticking the box
to actually diving in and Performing the
analysis check I mean what who who
really who's aware of the Gen AI shift
and how it changes the expectation from
the GRC questionnaire deepness
H so not yet people are still not aware
of that currently vendi is the only
company in the world that actually use
this technology and we are still pretty
small so most regulator don't know us um
but it will probably change in the
coming three to five years H the GLC
industry in general is not very strong
in technology and not a very early
adapter industry uh so for this is why
we thought it's important for us as
people that care about what happens in
the world H to start our company in this
area because we know we know that
privacy and AI regulation it's it's like
it's important for us the human being
not just um as an entrepreneur but also
as a human being with
kids I see um I see kids
today when they are addicted to Tik Tok
for
example I mean Tik Tok is
AI ER running and thinking about AI that
optimize the time that H people will be
inside um inside the network social
networks right this is function of the
AI in The Social Network they want you
to be in there and to be engaged in
there um so if you really want to fight
those um er those phen this this kind of
stuff um you have to you have to give
the regulator and the industry a way to
identify it and to make sure that
companies that are complied sure and so
so who are the buyers then of an
evolved an evolved solution like vend
because it sounds like a big prompt to
asking these questions is coming from
cesos Regulators Etc who who is then
asking the question that vend then helps
respond to yeah so we have two types of
customers one one type of customer is
the company's is a typically large
companies that do verify their
vendors and so for example there are
some Industries in which you have teams
of 50 or even 100 specialist just
reviewing
vendors just analyzing this information
it's still not enough but for them it's
really important because they really
care about risk and they do the best
verifying their vendor and with vendi it
will be the first time that they will
actually be able to do it so this is one
kind of company Enterprises that uh
either because of Regulation or because
of Security Management will want to
verify each of their
vendor and the other type of our
customers is the actually the technology
vendors they want to be able to respond
H to questionnaires more efficiently and
more professionally
and this is why they are our customers
so that they um they can use it to
better respond when they are assessed
what is the actual product flow of vendi
in this regard how you know if I'm a
user how does it how do I actually use
it h so if you are a an Enterprise that
want to verify vendors you simply
provide us with h the vendor's details
like email and uh let us let us know
about about yourself in terms of what is
interesting for you and for each vendor
what's the kind of information you want
to get about this vendor H for example
is it do they does this vendor have your
um will have your sensitive information
or customer informations Etc and then we
do we run the entire process for you we
via the platform we will generate the
questionnaire or use questionnaire that
you define ask the vendor help the
vendor to autocomplete based on their
documents and to find the most relevant
section in each document for each one of
the question and then when you will get
back the responses you will also get um
like a grade of vendi output
professional this response
is and based on that and on the grade of
the responses and the grade of the
evidence of the vendor you will get a
rore for each of your
vendors how do you s how do you see them
gen fitting into this you know where
which which aspects of generative AI
ecosystem Empower you to be able to do
this a lot more efficiently and to and
it sounds not just you're not just
saving time but you're also mentioning
that you're able to go deep deeper and
more in depth into the offerings right
yeah so one aspect is the ability to
analyze the response of the question the
question is free text and the response
is free text and you need dedicated
model that was trained specifically to
understand this area to say okay this
response is professional or not
professional and if it's not
professional then why why what is
missing what should you as the buyer ask
the the vendor as a follow-up
question H so this entire thing is
generative AI H another aspect is the
assessment of the documents H we need to
understand exactly what's written in the
documents and the for example in the
audit reports but also what is missing
over there because many time the vendors
want to make this audit as simple as
possible so they can pass and you need
to see how professional they are based
on what they choose to
share and the third thing is that we
auto complete the question the responses
to the questionnaire based on previous
information so we really if you look er
um
inside inside the solution you will see
like 90% Ai and 10%
engineering wow going back to the
um first days of vendi what you know the
founding Story how how did this whole
company came to
me um so it was me and my and my
co-founder which is also my friend we
work together for seven years at
broadcom er we knew what we want to
solve uh this third party risk
management H but the technology was not
mature enough yet to solve it the way we
are solving it now H so we started with
the vendors with just autoc completing
responses based on past responses and
then the solution was evolved over time
we are both me and my co-founder are AI
um experts and H we also have a mainly
my
co-founder strong understanding in GLC
and then we hired the um
so we we got um we first started as
Engineers we started with a product H we
even had like free paying customer
before raising any money just me and my
co-founder playing a and it it was not
small companies it was for Nasdaq
companies ER that paid for this uh AI
based solution
ER and then H then we got first money
and
things we could hire like better AI
expert than us and better GRC expert
than us and we are evolving since then
uh we raised um seed ER like few months
ago H from nfx disruptive AI
cardan leading um Le leading
by now we have almost 100
customers yeah it's
um I
mean this is the the advantage of being
the only one that use generative AI in a
certain industry I'm sure it will not
last for long but our goal
is H to to make the most of
that and so when you have 100 customers
I mean you're just at this point you're
already able to provide the
software um and they can then leverage
it autonomously to to the communication
is you're already sort of hands off with
it h I
wish h no it's a like we learn a lot
from speaking with customers I I
wouldn't even even if I could do it like
with
the like completely automated that you
wouldn't want to because at the end
there is really like Endless
Possibilities to innovate in this area
with the generative Ai and we do want to
keep keep going and keep adding use
cases H we want to make sure that even
when the other companies will do what we
are doing now so we will be we will
already be in somewhere else um and so
we we really want to keep this um
technology Gap and product Gap from from
everyone else H So currently we are
still not in the in in the phase when we
just want to scale with the same product
same thing just scale scale scale ER we
we really want
to optimize the product uh so that when
we start scaling it will be scaling
100% udy thank you so much for spending
this time with me um obviously you know
you know a lot about the space and I
love how you know we started this
conversation about the evolution of of
the GRC and the these questions and
being able to to identify the vendors
properly and to make sure that the
organization is secured if if before um
it was mainly ticking the Box because it
was too much and too complicated and too
cumbersome to look at hundreds of
vendors and dive into them now through
through the new tools in the AI space
were able to leverage what it sounds
like much smoother workflow to enable
organizations to perform this vendor
check but also to be compliant and to to
get their security right obviously with
the impact being less breaches and less
problems down the line so wishing you
best of luck udy um um it sounds like a
great journey and a great company and
excited to fall from the side so thank
you for joining me here thank you so
much for having me it was great thank
you very very much
[Music]